[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on m'a proposé d'être commissaire d'une
exposition au fait t'es marquer
l'anniversaire des dix ans de
l'établissement public de paris saclay
et d'emblée le commanditaire les
interlocuteurs que j'ai eus ont accepté
l'idée non pas de faire une exposition
traditionnelle ou choisir et des oeuvres
déjà existantes
mais ce qui est assez rare et assez
audacieux de passer commande un certain
nombre d'artistes étaient en liberté à
partir d'un choix d'une première
proposition d'artistes que j'ai fait
l'idée c'était demandé à chaque artiste
de réaliser des oeuvres faites
spécialement pour l'exposition et en
prenant en compte la spécificité de ce
que recouvrait l'ensemble du territoire
sous l'appellation l'établissement
public d'aménagement paris saclay en
discutant un peu en regardant un peu cet
ensemble que je connaissais mal je
connaissais par ailleurs mais mal ce qui
m'a paru évident de suite c'est de faire
une exposition autour de la notion
paysage au sens large du terme avec la
clé trois sens de paysages paysage
humain paysage urbain paysages naturels
et ensuite l'idée c'était de multiplier
les regards de multiplier les points de
vues il ya trois photographes
enfin trois artistes qui utilise la
photographie un plasticien qui est un
artiste numérique qui fait des camps
environnement numérique des
installations
numérique un peintre dessinateur
sculpteur installateurs et un
dessinateur par tous les artistes ont
visité le territoire l'ont arpenté et de
l'idée c'était que chacun remonte de
cette traversée des oeuvres des points
de vue qu'est ce qui les intéressait
qu'est-ce qu'il retenait qu'est-ce
qu'ils avaient frappé et donc non
seulement ils ont tous joué le jeu mais
ils ont été très généreux puisque au
bout du compte on aura à peu près 70
heures tout très très long format de
pharmaprix moyens qui vont être exposées
dans théoriquement cette nuit ville sur
l'ensemble du territoire et y aura sans
doute aussi une étape à paris
[Musique]